[Music]
the final trailer for Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker has arrived with a bunch of
new footage and now that everyone's had
the chance to have a good cry let's take
a look at everything we learned and what
we can maybe expect when the movie hits
theaters right now on the ketchup out of
all of the intense new visuals to this
trailer delivered of various characters
and locations perhaps the one moment
that is resonating most with fans is
what appears to be c-3po saying a final
goodbye to the rest of the crew taking
one last look say bye friends that's
pretty much the line every fan will be
saying once lights go down in the
theatres on December 20th and if that
had you reaching for tissues don't worry
according to reactions on Twitter you
were definitely not alone but that
wasn't the only buzzy moment that helped
put a pork sized frog in people's
throats seeing as how the trailer was
released on what would have been Carrie
Fisher's 63rd birthday hearing Princess
Leia as part of the voiceover at the end
was extra moving oh then there's the
site of Rey and kylo Ren appeared to
smash Darth Vader's helmet together as
part of their ongoing reloj love-hate
relationship but that had some fans
wondering if they saved anything for the
movie my guess is yes most definitely
we're gonna get more surprises and we
got more of the guy everyone loves to
hate Emperor Palpatine there was new
evidence of his return including a shot
of an emperor like throne that's
actually a Ralph McQuarrie design that
was not used for Return of the Jedi it's
not the first or the last time you're
gonna hear Ralph McQuarrie's name
mentioned with this new trilogy
we also heard more of his voice and not
just that creepy Emperor laugh and what
appears to be a brief glimpse of him or
at least his hood at the end well that
could all be from a forest stream the
appearance of an imperial star destroyer
emerging from ice suggests the Emperor
and his empire could physically be
crashing the party
we other familiar sites we saw in the
trailer for the saga capping adventure
include a free shot at Rose our first
look at the whole gang aboard the
Millennium Falcon which has to bring a
smile to your face and Rey hanging out
on a planet that looks a lot like a
forest moon of Endor complete with
wreckage from Death Star number 2 does
that mean more ybox
I hope so I don't know how you feel
about it plus we know the resistance is
building its forces back up after some
time has passed since the events of the
last Jedi and they're still trying to
fight the good fight and with that it
looks like there's gonna be some serious
space battles going on
that's something fans have wanted more
of there also appears to be a glimpse of
good guy ship the ghost from the beloved
animated series Star Wars rebels but
does that mean we'll get a live-action
look at rebels here O'Hara
add that to the list of things we're
hoping for the Empire must be jamming
all frequencies as far as new characters
there were brief shots of Babu Frick and
Keri Russell's helmet clad Zuri bliss
and the c-3po scene and then there are
these horse looking animals that brought
back some serious nostalgia from the
tauntauns on the ice planet of Hoth and
the Empire Strikes Back and along with
the new trailer came two new very
different posters with a couple more on
the way the IMAX one is giving us some
serious comic-book vibes and the trailer
release also coincided with tickets for
the movie officially going on sale too
soon for a December 20th release
not if it's Star Wars brush it together
now it's time to kick it over to you are
you excited for the rise of Skywalker
did the trailer show too much not enough
or was it just right let us know your
thoughts in the comment section and good
news our first book rotten movies we
love is out now it celebrates 101 movies
on the green end of the spectrum that
are worth checking out as always thanks
for watching another episode of the
ketchup if you like this episode and you
want to see more subscribe and click
that Bell icon I'm Mark Ellis and you
love me I know
[Music]
[Music]